hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
binary tree level order traversal it's
basically just like it sounds so we're
given a binary tree
and we want to return the level order
traversal
of its nodes so basically going through
every single
level of the tree and going from left to
right
so for example for this tree we have
this level
so that's going to be one list we have
the second level
9 and 20 and then we have the third
level 15
and seven so we have one two three lists
and these lists are going to be put
together and that's going to be
our result the three lists in that order
so to understand what we want to do is
pretty straightforward right so
basically we have the first level right
go from left to right
we see that there's only a single node
in this level three
that's going to be one list we see the
second level right that's what we want
to do we want to traverse this
tree every single level right one level
at a time
going from left to right so the second
level
we'll see 9 and 20 right we want to add
that to a
separate list and lastly we'll get to
the third level
going from left to right we have a 15
and then
a seven we're going to add that to the
third list
and so we've traversed the list in level
order traversal and each of these sub
lists are going to be
put together into a single list and then
that's going to be our results so that's
what we want to do we
know that that's pretty straightforward
so
the only question now is do you know an
algorithm that can do that
that can traverse it level order and if
you don't
the algorithm is breadth first search so
we want to run
breadth first search on our tree
and then add the values into lists
and the second thing to notice is do you
know
how to implement this breadth first
search so we need to know
this is the algorithm to use and now we
need to know how to implement it and let
me show you how to do that
so we have a tree and we want to run a
pretty standard algorithm
on that tree called breadth first search
and you might know how to
already implement this algorithm you
need a q
data structure because we're going to be
inserting elements
to the right meaning we're gonna you
know insert an element here here
here right we're gonna be adding
elements to the right portion
and we're gonna be popping elements from
the left portion so as soon as an
so basically we're following first in
first out right the first element that
gets inserted
over here is going to be the first
element that gets removed right so
that's the order
we're going to be doing things in so the
first thing we're going to do is take
the first element
3 and add it to our queue this is based
basically to initialize the queue right
and we know we're creating
sub lists right so what we're gonna do
now
is see that okay how count how many
elements are in our queue initially
right there's
one element in our queue so we're going
to basically
remove one element from our queue we're
going to see okay the 3 is in the queue
now let's get rid of the 3 and add it to
a sub list
right now the queue is empty so we know
that this
sub list is complete and what that tells
us is basically we
we went through the entire first level
right
that's what we're trying to do we're
going through every level we know that
the first level only had one element in
it
so now we're done but when we pop that
three we need to add its children
right it has two children it has a child
nine
and a child twenty so we're gonna add
those children
to our cue and we're to do it from left
to right because that's important right
we're doing this from left to right so
we're going to add a 9
then we're going to add a 20. okay so
now we want to go through the second
level of the tree right so we're going
to have a sub list for the second
level clearly we have two elements
in our queue so we're gonna basically
pop these two
elements from our queue from left to
right
so the left is nine we're gonna pop nine
from the queue add it to the sub list
so nine is added to the sub list and
notice how
nine did not have any children right so
we don't have to add any children
for nine into our queue so next we still
remember we had two elements we were
trying to remove we have two elements in
this level so let's
now pop 20 so we can add 20 to our sub
list right so now
clearly this level is complete we added
both nodes in the order 9 and 20
to a sub list but notice 20 had a couple
children had 15 and seven so as we
remove
20 from our q we're adding its children
to the queue
for the next level right because we know
we want to keep
going down a level so when we get here
the values will already be added to our
queue so
15 and 7 are added to our queue we're
done with the second level now time to
go to the third level
we see that there's two nodes two values
in our queue
so we're gonna pop both of these values
first we pop 15
add it to the sub list for the third
level
and then we pop seven add it to the sub
list for the third level
neither of these nodes had any children
so now we're done we know we're done
because our queue is now
empty right there's nothing left in our
queue
so we created a sub list for every
single
level and as the question wanted us to
do we're going to package
all three of these sub-lists into one
list and then return
that as our result so we're really just
doing a breadth first search algorithm
with a queue on this binary search tree
and since we're doing it like that
the time complexity is going to be o of
n we're only visiting every single node
a single time
the memory complexity is also o
of n because our q at any given point in
time
our q could have up to n divided by two
elements in it because the biggest level
of a tree
could be n divided by two that's how
trees work
binary trees at least and so we know
that n
divided by 2 can be rounded to big o of
n so the memory complexity
is big o of n with breadth with breadth
first search
so with that being said let's jump into
the code
so first let's initialize an array for
the result
and we also remember want to have a q so
in python
we can do that with collections dot deck
this will give us a q and the first
value we want to initialize this q
with is the root node that we're given
so with that we can start running the
breadth first search and we're going to
run breadth first search
while our queue is non-empty remember
and since the queue is not
empty we're going to get the length of
the cube right so we're going to get the
number of
nodes or values that are in this queue
currently and we're going to go we're
going to loop through
every single one of those values this q
length is basically ensuring that we we
iterate through
one level at a time we're going through
one
level at a time and with those nodes
from that level we're going to be adding
them to its own
list right and then we're going to add
that list to the result
list so i'm going to loop through every
value in this queue currently so for
q length i'm going to pop nodes from the
left
of the queue right first in first out
and it's technically possible that the
node could be null
so i'm going to have a check to make
sure it's not null
then we're going to take the node value
and
append it to the list level
and and don't forget this is also
important that to our queue
we make sure to add the children of this
node so node.left
and node.right technically these could
be
null but that's why we have this if
statement
so then when the next loop comes around
right we come around to the next
iteration
of the while loop it'll make sure to
check that these nodes are non-null
before adding them to its own
level list okay so now we have the loop
in place that's going to iterate through
every node of a single
level after we've done that entire level
what we're going to do
is take our result and make sure we add
every single level
to that result right and then we're
going to keep running
this outside while loop the outer while
loop
until there are no nodes left
in our queue that's how we know we've
gone through every single level
added it to the result and then at the
end we can finally return the result
and one last thing we want to do is make
sure that
if we're adding a level to the result we
want to make sure that level is
non-empty because we know technically
our queue could have
null nodes we're not adding null nodes
to the level list so
we want to make sure that level is
non-empty if we're adding it to the
result
we can run the code and see that it does
work and it is pretty efficient this is
a breadth-first search
level order traversal of a binary tree
and we did it in linear time and i hope
that this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon